[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 27th of
July I'm Kate Andrews the spectator's
economics editor and your host this week
coming up on the show
is the labor party a friend of business
the donations are flooding in from
different parts of the party including
the blairite way can kyostana maintain
this while keeping the unions and the
left of his party Happy I'll be speaking
to Katie balls and former labor advisor
John mctiernan could Ukraine win the war
using drones The Spectators fit Lana
more Nets is in Kiev meeting some of the
soldiers who are training to fly drones
and drop bombs she joins me on the show
since the Iraq War many people have
debated whether it was a mistake for the
West to invade but is it so simple to
say yes or no we'll hear from Douglas
Murray
labor has announced plans to change the
gender recognition legislation Nicholas
sturgeon in part had to resign over her
proposals on women-only spaces can the
labor party get it right we'll be
speaking to the telegraph's writer
Suzanne Moore
and finally our Wiki man Murray
Sutherland is with us for his latest
trick to boost your property price stay
tuned
before we get going why not subscribe to
The Spectator if you subscribe today
you'll not only get your first month
free but after your trial you'll pay
just one pound a week for full access to
our website and app or two pounds a week
if you want the print magazine too to
claim this offer go to spectator.co.uk
forward slash best
and do subscribe to our YouTube channel
spectator TV is picking up thousands of
new subscribers every week and you
should be one of them just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
now first up for the cover piece this
week our political editor Katie Balz has
been looking into Labor's donors under
castama more money was given to the
labor party by private donors and
businesses last year than buy the unions
has a strategy been part of a wider plan
to rebuild relations with the corporate
world Katie and John mctiernan a former
labor advisor join me on the show
Katie and John thanks for joining
spectator TV uh now Katie before we dive
into your cover piece for the magazine
this week I wanted to ask you about the
ongoing NatWest Coupe Scandal uh we have
now seen their Chief exec uh Dave
Allison Rose resign uh and that was a
very fast U-turn after just hours
previous the board suggesting that they
had complete faith in her is this the
end of The Saga or does it rumble on so
do things that end for two reasons first
The Wider issue uh which means being
debunked is still live Nigel farage is
not the first figure do you find that he
no longer has a bank account he's been
canceled by one of the main lenders and
therefore you have this week uh the
ministers Andrew Griffith the city
Minister meeting with the big Banks and
meeting Allison Rose was supposed to be
at but it's not because she's no longer
in a role to look at the steps you can
take to protect consumers from
effectively being barred because of
their political beliefs and other things
and so that will keep going and then I
think when it comes to NatWest
specifically and the Coots ninja farage
route and you see that nice farage is
now talking about how the whole nap West
bored in his opinion needs to go points
to the fact that throughout this and one
of the reasons Alison Rose has seemed
confident until obviously very early
morning is effectively that the board
were behind her and therefore what does
that say about the Judgment of the board
so you can see that's where the story is
starting to go and I think politically
is interesting speaking to figures in
government they were astonished and as
Rose effectively admitted that she had
been the source to the BBC journalist
which ultimately ran a story that was
not accurate about Nigeria's bank
accounts that despite that she thought
she could stay on but now there seems to
be a little bit of dividing line between
the Tories and labor with one labor
front bench effectively saying it's not
for the government to intervene and
leave it to NatWest which I think does
actually link to the cover piece we're
about to speak about because it's part
of this wider I think um position of
Labor of being pro-business and trying
to not be scary to business be the
friends of business when they can and we
have seen the opposition leader kirstana
come out and now suggest it was right
that Alison Rose stepped down but as you
say Katie there's this growing divide
between the trade unions and the
Grassroots members pushing for
radicalism and kiosama more generally
who's pushing for moderation and near
cover peace looks at whose tip to win
yeah so effectively something we talked
about previously is uh you know which of
the unions which are
um the most influential in case Dharma
now the three big Affiliated unions
effectively he does have the support of
two Unison and GMB it's unite which used
to be very Pro Corbin which is the most
hostile but this came to head again last
weekend at the national policy Forum
where you had the Grassroots unite
another union leaders raising some
concerns and pushing all things on
workers rights the Grassroots for
example raising issues on free School
meals oh definitely wanting the label it
to be more radical now kirstrama as
tends to be the case these days won the
battle at the draft policy document
which is the beginning of thrashing out
the labor Manifesto and when as the
labor leadership wanted and the reason
that he can live with having unite the
union come out and say we're not backing
that document in full and also the
momentum the Grassroots group say
Britain deserves better is not just
because he has votes elsewhere
um it's because of the funding and the
financial model on which the labor party
now sits when kissed armor took over the
labor party he inherited plenty of legal
cases and fees from the corbyn era a
labor live the music festival that
wasn't particularly successful loss
making by quite a high number and
ultimately a really a cash strap party
now Jeremy corbyn funded labor by
largely going on membership which he
increased significantly over a hundred
thousand left when kissed armed take
over and also the unions and Ed miliband
had a bit more in private donations but
still his largest donors were the unions
and what we've seen kistama do and I
think as a purposeful calculation by he
and his team is if you are going to take
the route which they believe is the path
to power of moving rightwards in many
ways and that's not going to be
something which you can do I think
unless you have other forms of funding
as well and therefore they've gone back
to the Blair act model and which does
involve finding uh ultimately
labor-leaning or at least Centrist
millionaires to help fund you
John what are the risks to stalmer
upsetting the unions and the radical
left of his party
to look the unions I think we've
discussed this before
um uh me and Katie the unions have
decided that they want a labor
government that doesn't guarantee a
labor government but it's the beginning
of working together and going into
um the national policy Forum I know that
peers offers were very confident that
they knew that they could do a deal and
the thing is with the labor movement
with the union movement there's always a
deal to be done and you have to cut
through the noise from their conferences
and their national executive committees
and their delegates and just go what
does the union leader want what does
Sharon want from uh from unite what's
Christina one from Unison what does Gary
want from the GMB ask the question do
the deal and all the rest is just kind
of scaffolding to get there so I think
the unions have decided that they want
the unity required to get to um to a
labor government
to show that they're together and I
think one thing that the Casey touched
on it labor are much more pro-business
explicitly
vocally labor from the front benches
comment labor would be very very
doubtful about saying what a private
company should be doing is for companies
and the markets sort out who should do
what in the banking sector it's not for
government ministers and I've heard very
senior Business Leaders in the last
thing come on say to me
the problem with the Tory government is
they're very socialistic
um like the New Year Speech the curement
in East London when you talk about
Labor's approach to business and markets
lots of business people were there said
to me do you know what that sounds like
the kind of government I would want to
be working with and I think the
repositioning both of the unions and
with business has been a really
concerted strategy
um and the fact that you know what was
the weekend the national Forum what was
it really a story it was the dog that
didn't bark there was no Revolt there
was no major overturning no major
confrontation
um and look
I think normal people
to kind of side with Nigel farage you
shouldn't not have a bank account
because of your political views I think
he was a victim he portrayed himself
everybody actually was a victim and like
as a PR professional I think NatWest
moved too slowly you have one chance to
to explain yourself you explain yourself
fully and publicly you don't brief you
don't brief a story that changes and
then have a public story that changes
and another story that changes you you
know if you're in a sticky situation
stop tell the truth
the truth doesn't set you free but
changing your story condemns you and we
see that today with um Alison Rose
resigning in in the early hours of the
morning
um and of course don't take on the
government while they're a big
shareholder by the biggest single
shareholder in that west of the month
still
John of course NatWest is a unique
example because the taxpayer has a stake
in that West a 40 stake so it was
basically a guarantee that politicians
would have to comment on that
um but it is more broadly clear that
that labor are finally pulling together
after years of infighting the MPS the
unions to come together around a more
pro-business agenda but can that glue
really bind them together and keep them
together going into a general election
look that's a great question and
the thing which has always been the base
the fundamental base of the labor party
because one Union that um Casey didn't
mention in Indonesia unions is you know
the biggest Union unite second biggest
Union Unison therapy is GMB fourth
biggest I'll still the shop workers
union the biggest strength of the labor
party in the routing in reality is the
workers who work in the private sector
shop workers
um in the gmb's case defense workers uh
gas workers energy workers
um
and that grounding 86 of people in
Britain work in the private sector only
14 work in the public sector almost all
discourse about uh work and employment
is as if we all work for the government
we don't
um a danger of cul-dec for the Tories is
that they've got current Governors that
they focus on that the labor party and
the unions know
a growing economy is what keeps union
members prosperous in the end that's
what strike labor back to where it is
after miliband after Corbin's leadership
labor our bank wanting to have a growing
economy and the unions accept that they
can't grow without a growing economy so
look I think it's the fundamentals the
reality the gravity I suppose the
gravity of the political economy is
dragging labor back to a place where in
the unions can't pull apart and you look
at the other you look at the other side
look at the conservative party there's
no force that makes them want to work
together even though they're in
government and yet being in government
and wanting to be reelected should be
the biggest Force you have
Katie in your cover piece and as he
mentions at the start of this interview
you talk a bit about
um the Blair money that is returning
funneling back into the labor party but
should voters assume then that we're
looking at another Blair right form of
government
so the piece is about how labor is being
funded at the moment and that is
ultimately three different groups I
think broadly when you look at the
donations coming in so the unions still
have a say but effectively more is
coming from private donors and
businesses and what is that uh saying
about the direction of the labor party
as you say one group tends to be the
return of the Blair right donors so you
have Lord Sainsbury's back his daughter
Fran is back she's done a similian she's
also helping the fundraising efforts and
you have quite a lot in terms of Blair
out donors returning they then cross
over I think to quite a few donors who
are not necessarily donors under Blair
but what they have in common is they
tend to be quite pro-eu and quite a lot
gave money during the remain campaigns
and you have some for example you know
um uh businessmen saying that their
biggest problem with the Tories is
brexit so uh one donor who gave the
Tories 500 000 and it could go up to
five million ahead of the election
instead of all the Tory sins and wants
to make sure the tour is our power for a
long time effectively brexit is the
worst and so that does raise a question
I think as to what this group of ux so
many donors who are quite open about
being a very pro-rebain what do they
want to see from the labor government
because the neighbor's been very clear
that they won't rejoin the customers
Union at the single market and so forth
but I think you'll start to hear a
listen to business if you get a labor
government and then the other group
which I think is quite interesting is
Tory donors and there's been a big
effort trying to bring Tory donors
across to become labor donors which
merges a bit with the business
engagements so you'll have these
business figures be invited to meet with
Rachel Reeves and her Deputy Pat
McFadden and then they will effectively
um ultimately give a Spiel then you'll
tell if you would like to donate to this
you know let us know and I think here
they're not going for I suppose the most
died in the wool true blue Tory donors
but instead quite uh Center ground to
where we do is who they think they can
peel back because if the party looks as
though it's on the cusp of power that's
when I think lots of people say well
even if I don't agree with everything
they're going to do I like to have a
sense that I have some influence or I
know who to speak to and that's why you
now see a situation where private
donations are I think are up at the
highest level they've been since 2008
and and also uh for the first time I
think since records began more coming
from private donors and businesses than
are from the trade unions
John everybody likes to back a winner
but still this is a pretty confident
move from the labor party trying to pull
in Tory donors
historically the labor party when it
wins it wins because it has the backing
of the country and it is the recent
years that the last 10 years when life
was being very anti-business uh that
people look at and they go this looks
different this looks strange but from
the perspective of the labor government
that used to win the elections in 97 and
2001 didn't arrive it's actually it's
the behavior of the leaders in
opposition that's been
um eccentric and not the one that says
we should be back in business and again
it goes back to my point which is we're
founded by labor unions we're founded by
trade unions
unions have always understood that they
do not Thrive their members don't Thrive
the country doesn't Thrive with Working
Class People don't Thrive unless
business thrives and it's been a strange
moment in the wilderness that the labor
has had and so yes I admit it does look
it's
strange different from the previous
behavior of the labor party but it's not
different from the behavior of the how
Wilson government and the Tony Blair
government and I think the key is I was
saying government there
um and you know oppositions can act
differently but when you want to do the
right thing for the country and in the
end there's a consensus even in a sense
um this trust shared it we need to get
the economy growing she had the wrong
views and the wrong policies and they
nearly crashed the economy and the
markets had a message for us on that but
if you want to grow the economy as the
labor party and that's I've said this on
previous discussions about industrial
relations the labor party governs for
workers and for business it governs you
know for pensioners and for workers it
governs for young people and older
people it governs for the whole country
and so so if you're governing for the
whole country it would actually be quite
perverse to say I can't take your money
I can't ask you for my money your money
I can't discuss with you the kind of
policies you think will be right for the
country we're not going to take the
policies that you want but if we listen
to you we may improve the policies we
have so I think it's the labor party
returning to normal
um and it's been in a very very strange
journey I have to say and I accept that
um but actually it's the labor party be
much more normal to its history because
it is a labor party not a Socialist
Party
Katie last question to you
um and as as you know in your peace
labor is is coming to terms with the
fact that being in power getting money
getting votes realistically means making
in the words of Hershey sunac tough
choices no lifting the two-child benefit
limit no free School meals across the
board no radical extension of workers
rights
um but as they take the money and as
they hope to take the votes are they at
risk of also taking the title of the
nasty party
so I think moving from opposition to
power is always going to be a painful
process and you had last week when the
two child benefit rare first came into
the open and Sir kid starva trending on
social media as a nickname for kirst
armor because lots of people thought
this isn't what a labor government
should be doing and therefore I think
Rachel Reeves and particularly along
with his Starlight are going to face
lots of attacks from activists on the
left also some disheartened voters and
that's why those around kissed armor
Rachel ribs are trying to work out how
you can frame the tough decisions in a
way where you're blaming it on the
Tories and Legacy in the way that if you
think about there's no money left note
was used by the Tories constantly
Whenever there was a problem to try and
trash a legacy of the labor government
so I think there's things like that
going on
um and yes
ultimately the decision has been made
you have to be uh pretty restrained in
what you're promising you can see that
from the labor policy Forum this weekend
you can see it from the messages to
businesses
um we talk about you know John talks
about the party returning to normal I
mean I think the fact that I write in
the piece about somebody's business
figures who've been invited to these
sessions and Pat McFadden who is the
shadow Chief Secretary of the Treasury
and he has been known to say in these
sessions you know you can trust me
effectively and I'm obviously Loosely
quoting him
um because I was the first minister to
be sacked by Jeremy corbyn so and that
point of Pride exactly and that does
calm down the room yeah um
you know I think you are seeing
something from that as they try and move
to this Centrist position
John and Candy thanks so much for
joining me
next Ukraine has upped its training to
teach soldiers how to drop bombs using
drones could this tactic win them the
war spectator writers fitlana mornets is
currently in Ukraine and has been to see
some of the training she's with me now
Svetlana thanks for joining me on
spectator TV you are currently in keys
and before we get into your piece for
the magazine this week I was hoping you
could give us an update on what's
Happening
hi Kate currently there is a air raid
Alert in KU but the bay in Target for
the last few days has been on the SF and
Russia has been selling the city like
every night and destroying the ports
with grain the equipment because as they
left the grain deal now they want the
best to give some concessions so uh
audacity started with it all the time
right now and Ukraine doesn't have
enough air defenses to protect it and
today the landscape was talking about
that he actually received more of air
defense from one country he didn't name
it and said that we will put it in a
place that is the like the most targeted
right now he didn't name it but it was
obvious that we it would be Odessa
about the rest of Ukraine it's
the control fancy is going slowly
because of the
Minds well that brings us on to your
magazine piece this week Svetlana which
looks at drones which have become the
big business in Ukraine having replaced
many key aspects of conventional Warfare
um and they're crucial right now for
tackling
um the minds that have been laid can you
talk us through it
yes of course ukraines want to build a
significant Army of drones first because
it saves the lives of the soldiers and
second because they are very effective
on the battlefield because if you talk
about
reconnaissance drones they
they help to see where is the enemy uh
where their warehouses and they help to
direct the artillery where they should
strike so in also soldiers who work in
intelligence and a the Infantry they
need to go forward right now they first
send drones
and then they see where they can go and
where they can't and the strike drones
that can carry explosives they help to
destroy as well as Russian military
personnel and the the weapons that they
have so they are very much needed and
Russia has
many more drones than Ukraine that's why
the country has been trying to produce
them domestically because yes allies
help us but these amounts are not enough
big to keep everyday fight
so uh because of them
it's it's a problem for Ukraine that
because of the years of the bureaucracy
and red tape we had only seven companies
they were that were selling drones to
their state
and right now uh they are trying to
reform it and it has been pretty
successful because right now there are
40 companies selling to the state and
more than 100 producing drones but they
still haven't received the contract but
even without contract with the Ukraine
defense Ministry they can sell the
drones to anyone like volunteers they uh
ask ukrainians to donate and when they
have enough money they buy the drones
and they give them as gifts to the
soldiers
uh well you have visited a so-called
drone school and I have a lot of
questions about this but the first thing
I want to know is what is the school for
the school is to teach soldiers to
become drone operators because soldiers
who are currently on the front line
uh they they are allowed to choose the
profession not all of them but some of
them yes and if they decide they want to
become drone operators they apply for
school and it is completely for free
also it is a private school there are
only private schools of Journal practice
in Ukraine but the ministry of digital
transformation they pay for every
soldiers who graduates
to the con to their school
and I saw when I came there the soldiers
were really excited because their first
day they learned on simulators on
computers have to fly for one week and
the next week they learn in their big
closed building and I have to fly the
Drone already and on this Earth week
they go to the field and learn how to
slide the Drone there and have to drop
the explosives of course they are fake
but the school also told me they would
like the soldiers to work with real
explosives before they go to the front
line as run operators because they
must know what is the danger of it and
have to work with it correctly because
anyway you are more relaxed when you
drop a fake pump you know while you are
training but the schools and drone
factories are not allowed for enough to
to make the explosives
and it's the government needs to make
reform on it too to allow them or to
make the explosives for the drones or to
assign the instructors or trainers who
will come from the military factories
that produce the explosives and they
will train them so that's still a big
question so how quickly can a complete
novice learn the basics of becoming a
drone controller and then be out on the
front lines presumably doing so
it depends because there are different
types of drones for example for their
reconnaissance they need like one week
but for example drones with the uh that
carry explosive takes three weeks but
unfortunately there are some schools
that offer like three days training or
one week training for the strike drones
and it shouldn't be like that because
it's dangerous when the soldier still is
not
um doesn't know so well have to operate
the Drone and he goes to the front line
and he takes that explosive and he in
their endangers those next to him
um you write in your piece for the
magazine uh that it isn't just people
who are going through this drone school
um who are aiding the military you met a
man who was using his engineering skills
and background to make homemade drones
which he then supplies to the military
and not only is that very interesting
about you know how Ukraine is getting
its Weaponry it also suggests that
they're really desperate for supply
yes of course and most of these people
who right now make drones they did they
have engineering background but they
just started it by themselves with their
own funds the government didn't help
them they started like they made one
drone five drones then when people
started buying them then they increased
the production but as they often tell
they make the drones on their knees
because they don't have the buildings
where to make them the right equipment
and everything costs money and also when
we talk about
um
they're drawn components and Thursday
are very difficult to find they're
expensive in China tends to sell those
components more to Russia than to
Ukraine so sometimes they end up buying
a Chinese components that were sold to
us or other countries and buy them for
insulated price price
and that's also an issue but uh if they
receive the contract with the Minister
of Defense then they uh can sell much
more because already the government
uh makes requests and
they want to buy many more neurons than
volunteers can afford and right now uh
the the private companies that produce
drones they need only six weeks to
receive their
a contract with the state earlier it was
taken years to do so and right now they
just need to show how the Drone Works to
show him on the field to the the state
will evaluate it and evaluate the price
and then always done and they can supply
for the state also
the question very for the state to take
the money to buy these drones because uh
reconnaissance drones costs like from 3
000 pounds if we talk about strike
drones it can be 3 30 000.
so for Ukraine
um right now they buy drones using
donations a lot because Ukraine has the
project called United 24 and it is it
was created last year by the lensky and
it is gathering money for buying more
drones for Ukraine
um you read about the advantages of
drones that they are relatively cheap to
make of course there's the lower risk to
a soldier's life because they're remote
controlled but let's also talk about
some of those disadvantages what have
you been finding out
these disadvantages of drones that there
are so few of them and there are no
still not enough drone operators or
well-qualified ones
because Ukraine is making amazing drones
different drones they can go on water
they can fly they use right now even
artificial intelligence that when Russia
tries to down the Drone and the GPS
doesn't work anymore so anyway drone
flies to Target and hits it so Ukraine
has a lot of nice scientists engineers
who can make the storms the
disadvantages there is few funding and a
few components for making them in big
bunches you know to increase the
production because this this war is
different from the others because it's
very technological and it's like
the 30
kilometers between the two armies they
are just full of drones reconnaissance
drones are striking drones and they like
they have even fights in the sky between
the drones so it's completely different
and ukrie Ukraine needs a lot of them
because they save the lives and yes uh
in my piece I mentioned that
approximately
10 000 drones per month Ukraine loses
it it is not an official number from the
government but there were some like
researches
saying that
and but it is better to lose drones than
soldiers of course so you print it as
many as to make them as many as they can
and
federov the minister who is in charge of
the army drones he told me that right
now in the last two months they signed
more contracts with their drone
manufacturers in Ukraine then in the
last year so it's getting better
Selana thanks very much for joining me
next spectator columnist Douglas Murray
has written this week about his
conflicted thoughts over the Iraq War
many now see The Invasion as a grave
mistake but for others it's not that
straightforward he joins me now
Douglas thanks for joining spectator TV
you have written your column this week
on your views about the Iraq War and I
just say conflicting views uh you felt
around the 20th anniversary back in
March that you weren't quite sure what
to say about it but something else has
happened recently that has prompted you
to write about it this week tell us what
that is
yes that's a very sad death of the
former labor mpm clue it uh and could
left the house comments a number of
years ago but she was an extraordinarily
long-serving and devoted labor MP she
was one of I think it's right to say one
of the sort of slightly awkward Squad
that all parties have who don't fit into
any particularly clear Clique and
therefore don't always rise as as high
up on on the greasy poles perhaps they
should but but an code was a really
remarkable woman and uh not only
represented her constituents with with
greater plan but uh was also perhaps
most famous in recent years for her
internationalism and specifically and
it's what brings me to write about the
second Iraq war
um her Devotion to the cause of the
Kurdish people Northern Iraq and clue it
traveled to the area after the unfiled
campaign
1988 when Saddam Hussein tried to
ethnically cleanse the Kurdish people in
the north of his country and she saw
firsthand brutality of that regime and
campaigned for decades not just
Democratic rights in Iraq for all Iraqi
people but specifically also to indict
uh Saddam Hussein for his war crimes
crimes against his own uh painful in
Iraq and that didn't have any success as
it were until 2003 when people listened
to the case she made in in great silence
I remember in House of Commons when in
2003 she explained what the horrors were
of the Saddam Hussein regime and that's
what brought me to really to write about
this terrible subject again which was
just that the complexity of it at a time
when I think some people from all sides
talk about the subject of Iraq a very
painful subject for Iraq with a sort of
degree of Simplicity which I think isn't
quite what it Warren and Douglas this
hasn't been and still isn't really a
left right political issue is it as
exemplified by the fact that you and and
fluid had very similar views on the war
no that's right I mean as it happened we
became friendly because and traveled to
Iraq together uh because we shared the
same view which was that the Saddam
Hussein regime uh was guilty of some of
the most terrible crimes against its own
people and and other nations of course
remember
that Iraq had been involved in a long
bloody war with Iran in the 1980s has
invaded Kuwait and that it was an
incredibly unstable as well as dangerous
regime uh and Khloe's work included the
documenting of the war crimes and the
crimes against humanity that Saddam
Hussein perpetrated and many people have
left and right felt the same way some of
her obituary notices have noted the fact
that she I think say erroneously have
said she became friendly with Paul
wolford's Donald brumstar I was not
quite true she met ramsfeld and
wolfowitz in Washington that certainly
and and and they and others were
interested in this and had been
beforehand nowadays there's a sort of uh
again there's a there's a you say
there's a sort of left right thing that
people pretend about this is on all
other issues but there were people from
across the political Spectrum in those
days who were equally concerned about
what it was what it meant for the
international order uh to have a regime
getting away with Crimes of the kind
that Saddam Hussein's regime did and
there was a sort of unity in those days
I mentioned in my piece that uh one
occasion anchor and I were visiting a a
Kurdish rights Center in Northern Iraq
and
um I was at least quite amused by the
fact that the
framed photos going all the way through
the the hallway and up the stairs were
of people like uh Paul wolfquitz uh
Donald Rumsfeld uh Richard Pearl then of
the defense policy board
um people who back home in America in
Britain were all viewed with Incredible
uh disdain disgust by that point but who
in this section of Iraq were regarded as
Heroes because they had argued the case
of the Kurdish people among other things
and their Liberation from the tyranny of
the Saddam Hussein regime and as I
mentioned it's just one of those sort of
reminders that you know history is so
much more complex when you're going
through it than when you look back with
all of the benefits of hindsight
Douglas you say in your column that
those who oppose the Iraq War 20 years
ago are not short of examples of how
badly it was botched by countries like
the us but you said that your views have
never been so black and white and even
to this day they aren't and part of that
is due to the experiences that you had
with Ann in Iraq I mean
yes that's right I mean I I was very
struck that there was an enormous
just polarism in those times when people
talk about things being polarized in our
politics today is you remember they were
highly polarized 20 years ago as well
um but I remember very very struck by
the fact that there wasn't very much new
you could say uh about the rock or quite
quite early on
um even before it began one of the few
things I remember noting somebody saying
that I thought was striking was Ian
McEwen who the novelist who at one point
and I can't remember it's in the novel
Saturday or in one of his cons around
the same time but he noted that that the
anti-war protesters
um if they'd have if they'd have been
aware of what they were marching for in
totality should have marched in silence
now why did he say that because although
there was a very good reason to say
don't go in at all it would also of
course mean the continuation of the
Hussein families tyranny over Iraq
including the inevitable succession that
Uday and kusai Hussein if therefore when
their father died uh and I was very
struck by that observation of McEwen and
I've always thought at the time it was
right
but hold that view against intervention
but note that that also has terrible
terrible consequences not least for the
Iraqi people and it's it's just
something I should say echo in my piece
which is uh I think everybody who's
ordered the wall have a lot more uh back
then than perhaps admit it now everybody
who supported the war has to take some
responsibility or at least cultivility
for the terror terrible things that
happened in the disaster of the
implantation the post
um the post-war period
and also and it says it's and as well
uh recognize that it was not as
completely black and white as some
people were now painted in red
I mentioned the piece that one of the it
was a on the first years after that the
uh Saddam Hussein regime full and uh
uncle and I were in the north and uh it
were there where Narrows the uh Kurdish
new year was being celebrated this was a
festival that had been stamped out
throughout the storm seniors uh as he
tried to rob the Kurdish people of their
culture and here they were able to
celebrate it again
um and and be free again
um for the first time in in years and so
rather at that point McEwen made I say
that I simultaneously can think that the
disaster of what happened across most of
Iraq and the terrible implementation of
post-war planet and also the fact that
in that corner of the country at least
uh it is true that a freedom came which
had not existed before and it I just
sort of think that story can't be lost
and it's one I try to bring out
uh Douglas you had a similar
conversation with Peter Hitchens and
Fraser Nelson on a very old version of
spectator TV about eight years ago and
I'm curious to what extent your views
have changed since then I I totally take
your point that it's never going to be
black or white for you but what do you
wish you knew then that you know now
oh that's a very good question
um
I think that everybody
was has to take into account the fact
that the principal claim of the UK got
about wmd turned out to be wrong
and now again it's one of those things
that people say well we knew that to
people
but as Bruce Anderson and others have
observed in past years there's no no
particular shame in taking the word of
your intelligence services and
government for granted on occasion
um and of course the fact that they were
wrong the WWE claim is one of the things
that has caused so much greater
skepticism not just about intelligence
claimers but about all claims by
politicians in the 20 years since I
think there have been a lot of
consequences from that
um not least in America with success of
Donald Trump and others who say you know
you can't trust the institutions and
there's there's definitely something in
that uh it's had consequences
um I think that I think the other thing
and the thing that that is being quietly
discussed over the last 20 years is
probably too early still to discuss
among those who are involved but was
exactly where and and when uh the
post-war period went so badly wrong
people forget that there was a period of
months where tunnel Rams felt there was
was hailed as a military genius even by
by his enemies uh I think probably now
the history says that that he and some
others who I knew took their eye off the
ball and I think that was certainly the
case uh there was it was it was it's
it's you know I remember Jermaine Greer
saying at the time and I remember I
didn't didn't highly agree with it but I
thought it was very very interesting
point I remember Jermaine Greer saying
the problem with war is you open
Pandora's Box and you just can't contain
it I I absolutely see the Wizards of a
bad observation of Jermaine Greers and
certainly I and I think others who who
were bullish about interventionism then
having seen what the surgeon was like
have certainly stepped back from from
supporting it again in other words if if
you can't do it well uh don't do it at
all but at the same time I think that
there is just this there's an attraction
that has come since Iraq to many people
on the right and left of a sort of
isolationism and I had anyway still
certainly don't share that I don't think
it's possible or desirable for a country
like America or Britain to Simply have a
domestic policy and not have a foreign
policy as well I don't think it's
desirable to believe there's many people
do particularly right in America now
that is it where we have no right to
feel ourselves in any way able to act in
the world I I don't accept that as being
the case I think that the case the cause
of internationalism and the left right
internationalism of the kind that I
included in others represented has taken
a serious battering of late
um but I think that there is also a
battering for being an isolationist as
well I think there is a battering for
those people who believe that you can
effectively let the world govern itself
or police itself or let the UN or other
International bodies be the only
Arbiters I think that view also takes
quite a beating uh so it's an EV it's a
constant ebb and flow that
um I would say that he would just have
to be and I was I'm certainly more aware
myself of the difficulty of navigating
between this Silo and cryptus
Douglas thanks so much for joining
spectator TV
this week the shadow women inequalities
Minister anna-lysa Dodds announced
Labor's proposed changes to the gender
reform legislation have they figured out
how to manage conflict between
transgender rights and women's rights
Telegraph columnist Suzanne Moore joins
me on the show
Suzanne thanks for joining me on
spectator TV so labor has announced this
week that it will be quote modernizing
reforming and simplifying gender
recognition law in practice this means
changing the way doctors Grant gender
recognition certificates what do you
make of the announcement
well firstly I think it was a strange
way that the announcement came out which
was a kind of
uh it wasn't announced by storm where it
was announced in in a guardian article
after kind of a way day where they had
to think things through uh and
for such a big uh change for such a
U-turn really I think it should have
been installed but that announced it
um I'm was personally very happy to see
the acceptance that sex and gender are
two separate things because that's
something that people like me have
argued for many many years it's it's the
common sense position
um
but I have a lot of reservations about
what labor actually thing given their
previous statements do you think it's at
all clear yet with the labor party
thinks uh you know it's it's become
rather Infamous that kirstama has
troubled in the past to Define what a
woman is for example
now I don't think it's clear
um I think it's not clear and uh
different parts of the party think
different things and it was only a
couple of years ago wasn't it that
starma told Rosie Duffield off for
saying that women have cervix so now he
thinks that women have so have a cervix
and men don't and now he thinks that I
mean I don't know what the percentage of
women he thinks now have a penis or
don't because that's also changed hasn't
met the last few years
um so I'm not exactly sure where uh
where they're going except clearly
they are looking for votes and they saw
what happened in Scotland and this was
not a popular policy and but this policy
will continue to be contested in
Scotland and in Wales so labor not
United on this
I think it's a move in the right
direction but lots of women I know in
the party I'm outside the politics field
that we have been trashed and we are
owed something of an apology if this is
now the policy I certainly want to come
back to to your views more broadly on
the topic um quickly going back to these
announcements as you said they were
revealed through the guardian and
Annelise starts the shadow women and
equality secretary uh was the one
putting forward these proposals uh she
noted that the smp's proposed changes to
gender law she said were Cavalier and
was trying to draw some distinction
between what Labor's trying to do now
and what the SNP were trying to do
earlier on this year the policies are
different but do you think the labor
leadership is in any way at risk of
making similar mistakes to what the SMP
did
I think we just don't have enough detail
um the people who picked it over are
looking at what self ID really means and
this move from having a kind of panel to
just one doctor and I can see already
people like Lloyd Russell Moyle saying
that that could just be a social worker
because they want to keep self-id uh
means that some people are still fearful
that self-id comes in through the back
door in in a way
um
I think one of the things
that should be really made clear about
the opposition to self-id from from
feminists or people like me is that this
has never really been about trans people
exactly it's been about safeguarding
women and children so for me those are
the two priorities that we Safeguard
um particularly gender non-conforming
teenagers particularly girls
um and that we safeguards in Single Sex
spaces so to safeguard Single Sex bases
we do have to have a clear definition of
a biological woman and I don't think
labor Set uh I mean I think they're
pushing towards it
but I don't know how much they'd believe
it given so many of the things that
they've said given that they've let
somebody like Rosie Duffield be publicly
humiliated
week by week without stepping in
um so
I think there's just a lot of distrust
and I think that if we if labor want to
win back women
um they have to prove they have a lot to
prove still on this you mentioned some
of the other women in the labor party
that you personally have been speaking
to have you noticed a divide amongst
these women over these proposals
yeah there is a divide in the sense
um that some people are saying come on
let's take this as a victory let's say
we've won the argument and we didn't
think we would and we've moved on in the
past few years that's one position
um and that's the optimistic position
and the other one is
let's see the detail of the policy let's
see
um how starma handles the activists in
his own party who are already
complaining a lot about this
um
I think we just need
more clarity and there isn't that much
Clarity in what has been said yet
um but this important distinction
between sex and gender identity that we
we've been in the position with self ID
and with many of these arguments where
this feeling of gender identity which no
one no one has ever really defined I
mean it's just a feeling
had to give way to the fact of
biological sex and that was the thing
that many many of us struggled with
because it was a denial of material
reality
um and the fact that they now will say
no these are two different things uh
that's a step forward I think most
people will see it as a step forward but
to see it as a real step forward we have
to see kind of the meat of it if you
like and Suzanne um my last question
you're not on the right of politics and
what does the labor party need to do to
win back support from people like you
and do you think they really intend to
do that yeah later would have to do a
lot to win that support from people like
me because
um it's not just individually MPS like
Rosie Duffield it's organizations like
the LGB Alliance women's plays labors
women's declaration people that they've
not let
go to conference people that they've
expelled from the party spent their
lives working for labor
um and in women's organizations they
yeah they have to they have to show that
they actually
understand what women's concerns have
been around this rather than just pay it
kind of some sort of lip service
um no I haven't I I won't be I I won't
be uh wound by this I would um I would
like some apologies
um I'd like some acknowledgment of why
this policy shifted I'd like I don't
want this rewrite of History where
things that people said a year ago two
years ago they're now saying the
complete opposite I am
you know I think again that's taking us
for granted
um and no they have to do much much more
Suzanne thanks for joining me
and finally do you want to increase the
value of your home while splurging on
nice overpriced lunches Stay With Me Now
Rory Sutherland knows what to do
hi Rory thanks for joining me so you say
in this week's magazine that you've
recently found a way to boost the price
of your home simply by having nice
lunches tell our audience your secret
so slightly mysteriously I own a um a
small Crash Pad flat nothing exotic in
deal on the Kent Coast
and the joke I make to my wife is that
the great thing about owning a flattened
deal is you get to eat for free and let
me explain how it works in about 2011
deal won the High Street of the Year
award from the Daily Telegraph
that was perhaps part of my plan uh
actually deal is also promoted quite
actively by various sort of PR companies
uh encouraged by local estate agents but
my plan is this that every time I arrive
I go and walk down the High Street and
indiscriminately almost by extremely
high quality foods at fairly high prices
and when I get back I bought some Nets I
bought some Artisan sourdough Olive
Focaccia for 5 45 and I bought a few
hair I don't know what heritage tomatoes
are
um but strangely colored tomatoes for
three pounds 50 uh you know maybe
something exotic in the seafood line and
I get back and my wife says well how
much did that all cost you I go
absolutely nothing in fact we're
probably up on the deal
and the way I figure it works is this
that
by ensuring the survival of overpriced
Artisan
um slightly gratuitous but high quality
food retailers okay
what happens is that at the same time as
I'm buying that sourdough loaf there are
two people behind me who are an Airbnb
couple visiting for the weekend from say
Fulham
and their natural reaction is well I
never actually thought of leaving Fulham
but um I see you can actually buy
overpriced sourdough bread here for over
five pans and loaf so I feel safe let's
pop next door to the local estate agent
and see what's on offer and so when I
say to my wife I've actually bought the
food for free my logic is that
um their visit to the estate agent which
is highly triggered by the availability
of high quality restaurants and
retailers
will increase the value of my house or
crash pad in this case by far more than
the cost of the food
now it's an interesting question because
I think it's actually uh you'll know
this is the economics correspondent it's
effectively a georgist argument
that the value that's actually created
in the community is created by the work
of people like retail and shopkeepers
and so forth but the gains
disproportionately go to the property
owners well Rory we'll get into the
economics of this in a minute but first
I want to ask you and Mom must afraid to
do so
how much do you equate your spending
directly to deal winning High Street of
the Year back in 2011.
I I played only a small part but uh you
know I've actually okay okay there is a
kind of you know there's a tragedy of
the commons problem there's a free rider
problem here that I would probably enjoy
most of the property games
um if I were not to participate and I
was simply to go to ALDI instead okay
but I see it as part of my communal Duty
within the town to drive up property
prices by effectively ensuring that
the retail ecosystem of the town is as
Fulham friendly as it possibly can be
and um it raises a very interesting
question by the way because I've always
had this hunch
you know you know how you know if if a
waitrose opens basically everybody
becomes a little bit richer okay as a
consequence of being able to say and
there's a waitrose okay
um I I think I think there's a kind of
magical combination of retailers and
Outlets
that effectively gentrifies a place
and it's obviously going to be a mix of
independent retailers and you know some
chains
um I didn't manage to save the Marks and
Spencers at the time that closed down I
alone was not capable of keeping that
alive I you know I don't visit quite
frequently enough or spend enough I'm
the whole property Market is it's not
really fair to treat the property Market
as a market
because is it consumption or is it
investment it's the only Market where
people basically spend as much as they
can afford okay you know nobody buys
toothpaste like that nobody buys cars
like that if we went into a car
dealership and said what's the most I
can borrow I've got a deposit of 50 000
pounds we'd all be driving around in a
kind of Bugatti Veyron or an Ask Martin
okay but the property Market because
it's had this reliable history of going
up in value causes people to abandon all
sanity and effectively the heuristic
they use is how much can I afford to
spend on property I want a property that
costs around that
okay that I think is a disaster because
it moves money from the productive
economy to effectively uh the inert
economy and it moves it away from
collaborative consumption to rival risk
consumption well Rory what I noticed in
your piece is that you were
fundamentally making a tax Point
um that perhaps uh you know the UK yeah
needs to look a bit more at uh how it's
uh taxing property maybe say through a
land value tax or something of the sort
um because uh people like you are are
getting away with free lunches and the
rest of it
I mean for example I'm kind of against
inheritance tax
to an extent but the extraordinary
degree to which inheritance tax is
really a tax break on wealth that's been
accumulated by doing absolutely nothing
is I think I mean capitalism to some
extent survives on a kind of consensus
that it distributes its gains reasonably
equitably
and if you have a world where I mean
I've had colleagues who older colleagues
typically a bitter older than me who had
many years where their house made more
money than they did
a colleague who actually owned a house
in Brighton and bought house in Brighton
in the early 80s you know for several
years in a row his house actually was
getting richer faster than he was
effectively that's not an equitable
system and so inheritance tax let's
leave that debate but the extent to
which property gains are untaxed
effectively just leads to high property
prices and as a result it's that you
know what we should be doing is
subsidizing the Artisan Bakers and
giving them a tax break because they're
creating a lot of positive externalities
and taxing my gains from the property
increase
what pisses me off is I I bought I
bought the place with no intention of
making any money I thought I paid 180
000 for it I thought I'm at the top of
the market here but I just want a place
by the sea
and it's ended up probably making me I
don't know
14 000 pounds a year and tax uh over the
period I've owned it this is not this is
not sensible you know I'm paying you
know I don't know if you're paying me
for doing this you're probably not your
stingy bastards but if I if you did pay
me 10 pounds for doing this interview
that Spectators going rate I'd be taxed
on that at 45 percent
okay I mean I think this is just nuts I
mean I'm sorry I don't understand why a
particularly unattractive form of
consumption which is you know first of
all the fact that you can live rent free
is effectively untaxed so you're not
taxed on that benefit from owning a
property but also then the capital gains
are also
this is nuts because it means that
whether you're rich or poor depends on
much more on where your parents lived
and when they whether they chose or able
to buy a house that it does on any
particular effort you yourself make I
mean I have to tragically admit okay I
get job applications
okay and you see there they're applying
they're sending their CV from their
parents house and it's some place like
hogsback Road beckinsfield okay and
they're applying to work for me and I've
never done this but I'm always tempted
to email back and say to be absolutely
honest why don't you just go on a seven
year Beach holiday and wait for your
parents to die because you know that'll
make more difference to anything you do
in life that actually applied for a
bloody job
and I I I I think this just I mean Henry
George was right all along yeah the
sooner we admit that the better
this is the the terrible situation we
find ourselves in when it comes to
housing in in the UK Rory you said you
wouldn't don't really call it a housing
market and I agree with you it's more
like a housing cartel uh you know the
system is not Equitable as you say
um you know so many people need the bank
of mom and dad in order to get on the
property ladder if that isn't accessible
to them they don't get on the property
ladder but the situation that you laid
out incidentally we're gonna we're gonna
have a lot of media sub stories about
people who over borrowed who now can't
afford to pay their mortgage okay well
indeed get bailed out if those people
get bailed out I'm bloody angry because
I always deliberately under borrowed
because I can remember interest rates of
10 12 13 well I've never really had a
mortgage that's more than 1.5 times my
salary and I don't see what this is time
when I get rewarded for my Prudence in
my in my book okay well and and to be
fair to the government they have made
quite clear so far that they are not
going to be subsidizing mortgages in in
any way but of course you know for most
people the idea of getting a mortgage at
1.5 times their salary is just truly
impossible now given where the housing
market is absolutely so what was that
you know well uh low for long interest
rates um have have proven quite
problematic on many friends but I guess
my last question to you Rory
um is are you are you concerned that
you've given away your secret about free
lunches and Rising house prices uh to
the masses because I'm in generation
rent a lot of us don't want to see
housing prices go up we'd like to see
them come down no
I'll give you another secret which is
very mischievous okay if you really want
to go onto the rent seeking uh world my
brother who's a astrophysicist did the
maths once as as he only he would and he
said if you divide the UK land mass by
its population everybody gets about half
an acre each okay so for a family of
four that's two acres there's actually a
shortage of space in the UK if you
divide the UK Coastline by its
population
everybody gets three quarters of an inch
so if you're really looking for scarcity
value it's actually beachfront seafront
and lakefront property that's the scarce
commodity not necessarily property in
the middle of a city Rory thanks so much
for joining me
that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode thanks again
for watching and do join us again next
week
[Music]